Are you an organ donor?
How much have you,
are you willing to part with your
heart and lungs, skin and bones,
cornea genitalia?
Why not just give away your entire body?
Yes.
This neurosurgeon says
he's close to achieving the
world's first successful body
transplant.
Most doctors are calling this
endeavor unethical if not impossible,
but what if it is possible?
What if you could replace any
body part without any trouble?
What if you could replace your whole body?
This is what if and here's what would
happen if there were no limits to organ
transplantation since the very first
successful organ transplant in 1954 the
list of body parts that you can give to
those in need has expanded significantly.
Almost everything from heart to
hands and eyes to intestines has been
transferred from one body to another.
In 2014 a mother made history by giving
birth to the first live baby from a
transplanted uterus.
It took decades of research and practice
to be able to pull off such procedures
and even the ones that have become
commonplace still face complications.
But now neurosurgeons,
Sergio Cannavaro and Shao Ping Ren
claim that they will soon transplant one
patient's head onto a new body.
Organ.
Transplants have come a long way but
swapping heads and bodies seems closer to
science fiction than anything like
real medicine. So how would it work?
How much would it help you and who
would you even be in one operating room?
A team of surgeons will prepare your
host body while in another room.
A different team will be tasked
with safely removing your head.
Your head will be chilled to about 10
degrees to minimize the risk of brain
damage.
Once blood stops circulating to your head,
your head will have to be drained of
blood to prevent any clots from forming
during the transition.
The biggest physical obstacle to a full
body transplant will be connecting your
head to a new spinal cord.
At this point,
no doctor has ever succeeded
in reconnecting a completely
severed spinal cord
and that's because there are millions of
nerve connections that would need to be
fused together perfectly in order to
restore full functionality to make the
cleanest cut possible.
Surgeons will use a diamond edge blade,
which should be sharp enough
to cut through the spinal
cord without fraying any
nerves.
Once that's done,
the next step is to glue your head onto
the new spinal cord using polyethylene
glycol, which is considered
to be a fusajiro capable
of rapidly refusing severed
neurons,
but so far in animal tests,
this part of the process has only
restored functionality to about 15% of the
nerves and the spinal cord.
So you can see why almost every doctor
who's read up on this procedure doubts
it's success and we haven't
even had an identity crisis yet.
Suppose your head gets a new body.
What happens to you?
We've been debating questions of identity
and consciousness for centuries and
we're nowhere near consensus.
Is your identity attached to
your mind or is it all of you?
Even if your brain stays the same,
you're going to have some new DNA.
If you decide to have children,
your new bodies genes will be passed on.
So are they really your descendants?
It's likely that your
personality would change.
To do you know about your
second brain medically,
it's called your enteric nervous system
and it's a bundle of nerves in your gut
that gives you, well those gut
feelings. 95% of Serotonin,
which helps regulate your emotions,
is housed in your gut.
So with your brain upstairs and
someone else's second brain down below,
who would this hybrid person B,
but suppose you can stomach
the existential confusion.
Can you really be sure that your new
body will accept you with any organ
transplant?
Patients are prescribed a variety of
drugs to prevent the immune system from
rejecting foreign parts.
So yeah,
you're going to have to hope your new
body can get along with your head,
but isn't the idea of your body not
wanting to be around you just a little bit
psychologically traumatic.
Thankfully these questions or nothing you
need to worry about today while a full
body transplant may one day be possible.
We've got other problems
to solve on our way there.
Meeting the current demand for organ
donation is one step successfully.
Reconnecting the spine is another.
We'll keep moving in the right direction,
but if you want to jump ahead and
join us again on another, what if.